it's okay if I take the front
door okay
best great acting is sometimes revealed
in the tiniest of details recently I was
struck by Tia swinton's acting while
watching this scene from the souvenir
part two just look at how much character
she's bringing to the way she's watering
these flowers even during what is a
fairly inconsequential moment in the
scope of the story she could have
watered the flow in any number of ways
that wouldn't have spoken to the
specificity of character that Tilla
switon brings to this moment it's so
naturalistic that the moment feels
almost documentarian you might be
tempted to think that Tilla Swinton
isn't even acting here that this is just
how she Waters flowers herself but
Swinton is a master of transformation
she pulls out all the stops even for the
tiniest of roles and what she's bringing
to this moment and this character as a
whole is incredibly intentional anyway
while I was watching this this funny
thought occurred to me is this some of
the best acting I've ever
seen obviously I don't think this moment
is specifically although Tilda swinton's
work as a whole might be some of the
best acting that I've ever seen but the
question stuck in my mind what is the
best acting I've ever seen it's a
question that immediately evokes big
legendary performances like Daniel de
Lewis and There Will Be Blood or Robert
dairo and taxi driver or Raging Bull or
Marlon Brando in on the waterfront or
The Godfather and while I love all those
movies find those performances to be
incredible work the work that is the
most iconic memorable popular and even
influential while it has a lot going for
it isn't automatically the best
personally I find it's often
performances that I least expect that
end up striking me to my core lingering
with me for months or even years after
I've seen a film so to refresh my memory
I looked back over my log of every movie
I've ever watched and made a list of
each performance that stood out to me in
some significant way that that narrowed
things down to about 45 different
performances and honestly I think every
performance on that list is amazing I
mean remember the harrowing intensity of
Michael fast Bender's work in hunger
Jack Nicholson in One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest is still probably one of
the greatest performances of all time in
my opinion Tony Colette and hereditary
makes me literally want to crawl out of
my own skin but if I wanted to make a
video about this I knew I would have to
narrow this massive list down somehow
which brought up a lot of fascinating
challenges and question when it comes to
judging the quality of performances for
example how do you even begin to compare
the incredible stunt acting that Jackie
Chan is doing in a movie like police
story to the hilarious yet grounded
character acting someone like Francis
McDormand is doing in Fargo there's a
highpe Pursuit ends here and then this
execution type deal yeah or the Nuance
depiction of dementia that Sir Anthony
Hopkins is doing in the
father something
wrong
how do you judge the subtle mysterious
power someone like Vicky kpes is
bringing to Phantom thread against the
explosive and magnetic power that Daniel
Kya is bringing in Judas and the black
Messiah you can murder a freedom fighter
but you can't murder
Freedom you know sometimes what's
impressive about a performance is the
physical dedication to a role Natalie
Portman trained for six months for Black
Swan Leonardo DiCaprio did this
oh
in the Revenant working through insane
conditions the extensive training or
physical difficulty on set can often be
felt through the screen and behind the
scenes stories about performances can
lend a role and almost Mythic quality
that goes beyond the film itself but
again most effort doesn't automatically
equal best and equally impressive to me
are performances that feel completely
effortless okay with me Ladi for example
I love Elliot gold as a lazy washed up
Marlo in the long goodbye I'm a private
detective I have my own agency those
girls are vicious a performance he pulls
off with what feels like a shrug it's a
character that seems to flow
effortlessly out of Elliot Gold's
Natural Energy as a person and I can't
tell if he's acting or just being
himself in a way that's perfect for this
movie and I've already talked
extensively about how impressed I am by
small subtle performances some of those
examples like Steven yuan in burning
Florence Pew in midsummer rised and
sound of metal are favorites of mine and
this is of course only talking about
film TV has some of the best
performances I've ever seen as actors
get to spend sometimes years in the
world of a character getting to explore
every Nuance of their psyche as the
actor spends so much time fully immersed
within the given circumstances of the
character's life within the context of
the story faced with all these questions
I realized that trying to narrow this
list down by some kind of objective
standard of quality was going to be
impossible that the only way forward was
going to be for me to fully embrace my
subjectivity here and narrow things down
not based on what I think are the best
performances but what I feel are the
best performances I would have to go off
of which performances most resonated
with my gut and my heart and using that
metric I was able to narrow down my list
of course leaving off a ton of
incredible performances that I hope you
tell me about in the comments to give
you 11 examples of the best acting I've
ever
[Music]
seen I want to start with this
performance from Oscar Isaac in inside
Lu and Davis there's some technical
difficulty here because he's performing
musically and acting while doing it
which is something few actors try and I
think even fewer pull off but that isn't
what impressed me for context in the
film he's trying to make it as as a
musician in a very harsh and uninviting
environment and in this scene he's
finally getting to play a song for a
record label I'm Len
Davis uhuh he performs his heart out we
feel the character's sincerity through
the performance of the
[Music]
song
Stone and then we see in such starkly
subtle detail how his sincerity
dissolves into exhausted defeat I don't
see a lot of money
here okay a defeat that has touches of
resentment and even grief all that in
such minimal expression and on top of
this okay the okay is so flatly
apathetic that somehow it plays
comedically for me I'm often drawn to
moments like this in film where it feels
like multiple emotions are competing
within the character for space or
against the character's attempt to
repress them as an aside here Ben from
Canada my editor for this video was a
huge help on this script because he just
so happened to have a ba and acting from
the Royal Conservatory of Scotland and
his input was massively helpful here in
keeping me from going too far off the
rails when it came to my technical
commentary about acting technique and he
tells me this moment from Oscar Isaac is
an example of something called listening
where instead of trying to portray
something the actor is just taking in
the information of the situation as the
character would react to it and whatever
the technique is that's being used
that's honestly what it legitimately
looks like to me to me as the viewer it
looks like Oscar Isaac isn't producing
something from within but is instead
simply responding to something as it
happens the important thing here though
from I think the perspective of the film
as a whole is that what I remember about
this scene is not the Nuance of Oscar
ISX acting what I remember about this
scene is the emotion that I felt
watching it I feel the defeat grief
apathy and then it makes me laugh that's
good
advice thank you Mr Gman it's only on
closer Examination for a video like this
that the Nuance of The Craft really
starts to stick out and I can begin to
understand why it makes me feel that
[Music]
way what you doing in here little
man
huh this next performance is one that
has such a warmth and a presence that I
was so enamored with the first time I
watched it that when I discovered that
this character disappears a third of the
way into the film it almost ruined an
amazing movie for me Moonlight is great
beyond mersel Ali's performance as one
but for me he Stills the show what is it
that makes this performance so magnetic
how did Ali manage to grab a much
deserved supporting actor Oscar with
less than 20 minutes of screen time Ali
brings the kind of death and subtlety of
expression that I talked about with the
last example but I think much of the
warmth and Charisma that I feel here
comes from how embodied and present the
character is the detail and the way he
moves the meticulously crafted walk the
posturing of the actor's entire physical
body is speaking to the character in
this performance you can see it in
little moments like this one just the
way he shifts his weight and brushes his
hands
it also speaks to the character's
awareness of himself the environment and
chyon we can see just in the way Juan's
moving that he's trying to make himself
less threatening and shyon more
comfortable to me the most impressive
moments of performance are ones like
this where the actor and the film itself
disappear and it feels like you're just
catching a glimpse of a real
human
oh it isn't just subtlety that I'm drawn
to Big intense emotions can be
impressive in a performance when the
actor manages to pull it off in a way
that feels grounded and real Brenda ban
in secrets and lies brings a rawness of
emotion to a performance that almost
makes me squirm in my seat it's like
catching a glimpse of something personal
and private that I shouldn't be seeing
the excerpt I want to highlight here is
from a scene that plays out over an
unbroken 7 Minute take while a
significant plot reveal that I won't
spoil here takes place I don't think a
single uncut take necessarily makes for
more impressive acting but when the
acting is great within that take that
locked in feeling can really increase
the intensity of a performance the
visual technique here also influences
the process though when an actor is
given the space to go through the Beats
like this uninterrupted the arriving of
thoughts and emotional Transformations
can happen in real time which can
absolutely help to produce the kind of
naturalism we get to see here I think
the scene ultimately works best within
the context of the film but watch this
moment where she transitions from
laughing to crying have you got a
boyfriend I'll give them all a wide
birth they got me into enough trouble in
the past I
[Laughter]
died it's the kind of move that can
easily feel like overacting but which
bin manages to pull off here creating a
gut-wrenching unsettling effect hello
Harry well well they seem giving you
quite some busy time yes I want to talk
to you talk to me of course come on as
soon as I thought about my alltime
favorite performances this performance
from Orson wells in the 1949 film the
third man came to mind oh the same old
indigestion Hol these are the only
things that help these tablets these are
the last can't get them anywhere in
Europe any you know what's happened to
your girl H she's been arrested tough
very tough but don't worry old man they
won't hurt her a lot of the examples
that I'm showing in this video are from
recent Cinema and some of this is
recency bias some of this is just that
I've seen For Better or Worse more
recent Cinema so I have a larger
selection to draw from when it comes to
choosing performances but there's also a
change that happened in acting
throughout film history a shift from a
more theatrical Style towards naturalism
and while I love that kind of Classic
Hollywood theatricality at times
naturalism and performance just tends to
connect with me more on a an emotional
gut level that shift and why it happened
what caused it is a whole video I might
do eventually but for now I'll just say
that I think this performance from Orson
Wells is one of the earliest examples we
have of the more contemporary
naturalistic style of acting that we're
used to today and if you look at the
rest of the performances in the movie
you can see the type of acting that was
typical at that time you're not going to
close your files at a dead man's expense
so you're going to find me the real
criminal but then Wells comes in and
it's like he's on an entirely different
wavelength you ought to leave this thing
alone have you ever seen any of your
victims you know I never feel
comfortable in these sort of things
victims won be
melodramatic it's immediately clear he's
doing something else entirely the effect
of this performance within the context
of the film is that it kind of feels
like everybody else is acting and
playing a character and then Orson Wells
walks in and he just kind of feels like
a real person when you combine that with
the fact that in the story this
character is hyped up beyond belief
before we even meet him and he has this
weird combo of like Charisma and
Sinister h
what fools we are not talking to each
other this way as though I do anything
to you with barely any screen time Wells
doesn't just steal the show here from me
he takes it for all its worth in a
daring and efficient Heist this is also
an example of how the line between actor
and writer can kind of blur Wells
himself contributed one of the movie's
most memorable lines that 500 years of
democracy and peace and what did that
produce the cuckoo clock
you'd be better off giving up yeah well
I'm not going to give up because what am
I what have I done this so far you know
what I mean I've gone so far with this
and why should I give up
now I can't give
up with patino one of my favorite actors
the difficulty became choosing an
example to highlight much of his work
has the kind of subtlety that I love but
he can also have this explosive
intensity that sometimes almost trips
into the comedic give me all you got
give me all you got but which a lot of
times is very entertaining and engaging
to watch ultimately though the
performance of his that has grabbed me
the most is his performance as sunny and
Dog Day Afternoon hello see no I just
saw myself uh what why you why am I
doing it yes doing what robbing a
bank
oh
uh what I I don't know what you mean by
that I'm robbing a bank cuz they got
money here that's why I'm robbing it in
the movie We're dropped into this
chaotic mess of a bank robbery Sunny is
not the straightforward Bandit we've
seen countless times in movies in many
ways the dramatic thrust of the film is
the question why is this guy robbing a
bank not while practically and
materially but what in his life kind of
pushed him to this place where he felt
this was his best option hello David
mammoth's writing slowly kind of unfolds
those layers as we go along but we see
and feel them kind of beneath the
surface in Pacino's performance long
before we start to find out those
details in the script Pacino really toes
this line between somebody who's lost
his mind and someone who's kind of a
sympathetic protagonist you can almost
root for one of the things that I think
makes this performance really engaging
for me is that he's managed to craft a
character that feels
simultaneously mysterious and motivated
oh oh I don't know you know life's so
funny you set a math full sweetheart the
performance feels grounded in a sense of
reality but it's not immediately obvious
to me what is going on with this
character's internal landscape when I
watch a moment like the big third act
phone call I have a feeling that if I
just studied his Expressions long enough
I could figure out what's really going
on with this guy there's a mystery there
on his face that feels like it could be
solved but importantly in order to
maintain the dramatic tension he never
plays it so simply or directly that we
feel like we've solved the
mystery while we're talking about depth
and complexity of emotion I want to
highlight Liv olan's performance in
Bergman scenes from a marriage liman has
done a lot of great work especially with
Bergman but this is the one that stands
out to me the
most in this scene the character has
just found out that her husband wants to
leave her and what Bergman with his
penetrating lingering gaze is most
interested in is simply watching her
navigate these emotions in real time
while she has to try to maintain a sense
of
normaly
I think it's an incredible depiction of
shock as with the Oscar Isaac
performance here it feels like we're
watching her respond to the
circumstances of this moment rather than
produce
emotion she's encountering and deciding
what to do with each of the many intense
emotions that are arising within her
moment to moment and it's incredibly
unsettling as you watch this internal
mental and emotional struggle play
across her face I like this because I
think it speaks to something very real
about our internal experience of
emotions as humans our most emotionally
intense moments aren't ones where we
just have One Singular emotion intensely
flowing through us just as intense can
be these moments where we ourselves
aren't quite sure what we're feeling
that some actors can express this
without the performance itself tipping
into just an incoherent mess is
incredible to
me please don't move so much
Elma I'm buttering my toes I'm not
moving too much it's too much it's a
distraction it's very
distracting Daniel de Lewis is another
one of those actors where it's difficult
to choose a single example but I'm
ultimately most drawn to his work as
Reynolds Woodcock in Phantom thread a
well
rabbit with a poach stick on top please
because to me this is another example of
an almost completely impenetrable
character one I barely understand but
who still maintains a real sense of
psychological realism it's not just
actors who perform roles some of us in
our day-to-day lives are inhabiting
sometimes very very elaborate characters
some of the best acting you'll ever see
won't be on a screen or a stage but in
real life the beauty of a role like
Reynolds Woodcock is that you get the
feeling this is the type of man whose
entire life and being is a kind of
elaborate performance he's obsessed with
image and has a kind of dictatorial
control over his environment and the
people around him and D Lewis performs
not just that surface performance that
the character is doing but also the
character underneath
the character and with Incredible
restraint only gives us occasional
glimpses of the man underneath where
many of the other performances I've
mentioned resonate with me because of
the emotional vulnerability of the
character here it's a character who's
desperately trying not to be vulnerable
in any way and he's up against another
character who desperately wants to see
his
vulnerabilities the result is amazing to
watch if you leave here I don't ever
want to see you again
or you can
stay everything I just said about D
Lewis's performance of Woodcock I think
also holds true for Philip Seymour
Hoffman's own work with Paul Thomas
Anderson as Lancaster DOD in the master
this is another character whose life is
a performance and perhaps what we think
we know of this world is false
information he's also a character that
needs to have a believable kind of
Charisma and warmth that makes his
status as cult leader feel earned the
other Twist on this performance that I
think makes it unique is There's the Man
underneath the character on top of that
Philip seamour Hoffman is performing
both of those
simultaneously and we get the sense that
the man believes the performance so he's
kind of caught up in his own per
performance I think pta's films are a
great showcase for acting because he
often lets the performances kind of
supersede plot and
dialogue want to get
[Music]
you on a slow boat to
China out here we're beyond the world of
rational understanding and into what
just feels like two humans bearing their
souls to each other Hoffman's work as a
whole is one of my favorite bodies of
work he's the late actor that I miss the
most he brought so much presence and
pathos to even small roles and comedic
bit parts that he
played uh you could see him if you want
can we ever have
lunch anyone else you and me
yeah I don't have some kind of in-depth
analysis for this next example from
Michelle Williams in Manchester by the
Sea sometimes it's not about the layer
or complexity of a performance it's just
about the raw experience of watching
someone struggle with their emotions
that cuts through the screen and into
your core
however my heart was
broken it's always going to be
broken but I know he is broken
too this scene I think is honestly one
of the most heartbreaking
pieces of performance I've ever seen in
my life just watching this clip
completely out of context makes me choke
up and tear up her tone of voice The
Strain and pain carried in her throat we
couldn't have
lunch I'm really sorry I don't think so
I thank you for saying everything that
you said you can't just die I'm not I'm
not I'm not I have such a visceral
response to watching this that I like
can't help but
perceive it as
real she can't see so good anymore where
is it where's the V where's
TR she got it no she ain't going to get
it you live out here all along yeah I
love if you're in a movie with Mersa Ali
Ryan goling Bradley Cooper Dan danan
Rose Burn and you still managed to give
the most impressive performance in the
film in one of its smallest roles then
you're Ben Mendon in The Place Beyond
the Pines there are two things in this
performance that really speak to me
first mendleson brings an incredible
specificity of character like I talked
about with mersel Ali's performance in
Moonlight a lot of work is being done
here in the way that mson embodies this
character physically the walk the little
movements deliberate adjustments in
vocal quality all of this speaks to the
character especially I think his poor
posture this was the first Ben mendleson
performance that I saw and I was
immediately hooked by it but I came to
appreciate it even more over time as I
realized how much he had transformed for
this role and for me personally the
specificity that he's bringing here
isn't just a random character it's one
that I recognize having grown up in
Rural America Ben mson wasn't just being
a guy he was being a type of guy that I
had seen out in the real world but who
I've never seen represented with such
Clarity in film this is also a case
where I read the film's script after I
had seen the movie and was amazed to
discover just how far this character had
come from what was on the page in the
script Robin is almost the definition of
a supporting role he's there mostly to
facilitate the plot progression for the
main character played by Ryan Gosling
but what Mendelson ends up bringing is
far from just a cog in the wheels of the
story instead we find a character who
has an immediate sense of Pathos and
tragedy best yeah best never seen
another one like best we're not told
about his past but we can immediately
see the conditions of this guy's life
and see his desire for friendship and
connection and Robin ends up being one
of the most quietly heartbreaking
characters in a movie full of
heartbreaking characters
this is so
disappointing no no we don't need all
that I've only got s
minutes passengers this next performance
isn't about emotional complexity realism
or depth in fact it stands in stark
contrast to most of the other examples
I'm showing here but great acting for me
isn't always about conveying heavy or
layered
emotion would you wear a shoe on your
head sometimes it's fun to just watch an
actor transform themselves again and
again in original and creative ways this
is one of the main reasons Tilla Swinton
is my favorite actor her work borders on
almost a kind of contortionism at times
I can't tell you how many times I've
been talking about how much I love her
acting mention her role in snow piercer
and the other person says that was Tilda
Swinton this performance from
Snowpiercer is a fun example of this
aspect of her work but I wanted to begin
and end this video with two examples of
her work that are at opposite ends of
the stylistic spectrum o yes can you get
the dogs out daring I don't want them to
hurt their feet it's all right it's all
right it's all right come
on because for me what makes her acting
career one of the best I've seen is not
any specific performance that she gives
but but the scope of her work as a whole
I honestly can't think of anyone who has
performed a greater variety of
characters with such a diversity in
style of performance she brings an
incredible dedication to every role I've
never seen her phon it in Swinton will
sometimes bring like Gary Oldman levels
of transformation to the most
off-the-wall bit part and then turn
around and bring a startlingly subtle
naturalism to another role in the same
year it's clear she treats every role no
matter the size as an opportunity for
the kind of transformation that you
generally only see from lead
performances it's fun to watch her work
because it looks like she just loves the
craft and enjoys the process of creating
new and original characters for the
screen even when it wouldn't be demanded
of her and it's work that feels genuine
to me while simultaneously being fun and
completely
unpretentious acting is a beautiful and
complex craft and like any art it's
highly subjective when it comes to what
resonates with specific people in the
audience these are the performances that
for me are like a great song you can
come back to them repeatedly and
immediately and reliably be transported
to somewhere very specific watching that
Ben mson performance for the first time
in years to me didn't feel like
revisiting a film it to me it felt
almost like bumping into an old friend
immediately all these memories from the
first time I saw that film came flooding
back because of this what actually makes
up the best acting I'll ever see or
you'll ever see is incredibly personal
so I'd love if you shared in the
comments the performances that occupy
that space for you another one of the
best performances I've ever seen comes
from this razor the Hensen al13 this
razor shaves better because of the way
the design of the head here holds the
blade it supports the blade along the
entire length so there's no bending
warping in the the blade and the blade
only extends past the Shaving plane
131,000 of an inch Which is less than
the width of a hair that brings a kind
of subtlety of performance that I will
honestly never be able to bring to this
kind of gimmicky attempt to integrate
the adre into the subject of the video
fortunately though I don't have to act
for this ad read I can just tell you
that I love this razor and since Henson
sent it to me over a year ago it's been
the only one that use when I want a
clean shave I feel really comfortable
with this razor it shaves well it feels
good doing it and Hensen is a company
that I think has both the consumer and
the environment in mind which is
something that I really appreciate most
Razer companies will sell you a really
cheap handle and then gouge you over
time on the cost of the replacement
blades not only do you end up spending a
lot in the long run on a very mediocre
shave but it generates a lot of PL
plastic waste that is unnecessary and
just ends up in landfills Henson flips
that whole model on its head you pay a
little more up front for a very high
quality well-designed razor head and you
can get cheap replacement blades from
literally anywhere it's only going to
cost you $3 to5 a year for the
replacement blades depending on how much
you shave and the entire body and head
of the razor here is really well
manufactured it it looks and feels like
it could last a lifetime going this
route is cheaper than both electric
razors and cartridge razors after just 2
years and it's a better shaving
experience on top of that for me it's a
no-brainer if you're like me and this
reminds you of like a safety razor which
you maybe already tried and gave up on
because it's kind of finicky to work
with and a little bit scary this is not
that this uses the same type of
replacement blades but it's a very
different design in the head that holds
the blade in a very precise way that
like a classic safety razor does not
classic safety Razer you have to be
really careful with this razor I feel
very safe shaving Against the Grain
putting pressure on I've never gotten a
Nick or a cut from it happily recommend
this razor to anyone who shaves the
shave feels great the razor itself is
really well designed and it's better for
the environment more sustainable they
don't even use plastic in their
packaging and if you go to Hensen
shaving docomomo flight and use the code
Thomas flight in the checkout you'll get
100 free replacement blades with your
purchase thank you to Hensen shaving for
sponsoring this
[Music]
video see now I just saw myself